There are two commonly used
print features in DesignaKnit.
The text format and the
garment notation format.
Many machine knitters find the
text format difficult to follow.
With a little extra effort.
You can create your own
cheat sheet following the
garment notation instructions.
The cheat sheet will make it so much
easier to follow along as you're knitting.
If you are new to knitting and garment
notation, this format is also called
the Japanese notation format, and
it may seem a bit cryptic, but I
encourage you to investigate using
it and add some of your own notes.
Let's look at a simple shaped sleeve.
The text instructions are detailed,
but they aren't visually easy to use.
Let's translate the Japanese
instructions and make them easy for you.
Your instructions here in DesignaKnit
may look different than mine.
I formatted them the way I like them.
Please check the tutorial "Japanese
Notation Format" for adjusting how
your instructions are displayed.
I'm using a spreadsheet for the math,
but the goal here is to make just a
little table for yourself to follow
each of the sets of instructions.
On row zero,
I'll start with 64 stitches.
Starting at row 3, I'll increase
one stitch on each side and
continue to increase on both sides.
Every 3 rows, a total of 15 times.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I'm pretty easily distracted
and I like to keep track of my
stitch count as I'm knitting.
What's missing in these instructions
are the stitch counts as you go along,
so add them to your cheat sheet.
Now if you get interrupted, it's easier
to know that it's time to increase or fix
an increase that you may have missed and
still keep your stitch count accurate.
At row 48 I'll also increase on
each side and repeat these increases
every 4th row a total of 20 times
on row 128 you're instructed to
increase again just one time.
Finally, we're instructed to knit
to row 137 with no increases.
And if we paid attention,
we'll end up with 136 stitches.
Again, I used a spreadsheet for the math.
For something easy like this, you might
just use a pencil and make some notes
along these Japanese instructions.
The point is to use these Japanese
notation garment notation format and
make notes for yourself to stay on track.